okay now watch wait so you're talking  because you're talking about how canelo  is  pushing him yes back guys yeah yeah and  he's the bigger fighter right right  right but you said on his back foot he'd  be on his back foot i fight on my back  oops right though because i was talking  so he he's on his back foot if he's  watch this  okay now we're both gonna agree you made  a mistake and you did it twice and you  did the same exact device right  back-to-back oops right now we don't  want to do that right right hey we don't  do that to each other no we don't do  that because we're brothers oh yes okay  when you do that what you're saying to  me is i'm not in your family yeah i am  and it's a rerun right yeah this just  happened there's a replay it's a free  everyone watching slow motion so why  would you interrupt me during a replay  when i'm in the middle of the car  because you already saw it right okay so  that's kind of three oopses in a row  and that's all right i'm just watching